for the carers in this nursing home
these are long dark days those struck
down with covert 19 are helpless this
man like so many others struggles to
breathe there are no ventilators here
the Care Homes owners have been hit hard
like so many others 55 cases here now
and 13 deaths in just under two weeks in
Cara's shoes I don't think anybody
really understands how difficult it is
on a daily basis we were on the same
ward on Saturday and told the story of a
man called John two days after this was
filmed he passed away John Allison was
76 and had until recently worked as a
driver delivering prescriptions in his
community described by his family as a
kind and gentle man he died in his room
with a nurse by his side it's just so
sad that we've not we've not been able
to give him a hug we've not been able to
say a proper goodbye to him I was up
there at home just wanting to be here
and it's sad that the first time that I
am here is after he's gone so many kovat
19 patients have died alone their
families unable to be there because the
risk of spreading the disease is too
high now the government wants to relax
the rules so that families can in some
cases be there to say goodbye to their
loved ones but loosening the rules will
require a more precise picture of how
widespread the virus is and that relies
on good testing from what we have seen
from spending time inside this nursing
home is that tests are key without them
care providers say they are working in
the dark not knowing who has coronavirus
and who hasn't and now the Health
Secretary has said tests are on their
way
can you just be specific secretary state
about numbers how many tests have you
put aside for social care and what is
the time scale that you promise to
deliver them in at the moment we have
spare the capacity in the thousands and
the capacity is ramping up to as I say a
hundred thousand a day by the end of the
month and the the vast majority of that
increase will be for the NHS and Social
Care as a whole
nursing homes are now in a race against
time because as each day passes the
situation gets worse
and as we filmed inside another life was
lost to this disease but past four days
and every shift that I've been on we've
lost somebody or portion our life that's
just sad it's awful and it's awful for
families
staff it's this Cove it 19 is just it's
just destroyed people I'm was included
and again just told me it's handed it
they are exhausted and they are drained
but these carers carry on even in the
face of unimaginable horror
okay Nick Martin Sky News Sheffield